[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up what is good how you living
how you feeling how you doing it is the
nfl draft
crash course presented by br gridiron i
got my main man connor rogers
and we are going to have fun today why
because it is the quarterback edition
i got all my notes because i'm here to
pick connor rogers
big old brain because he's been
following this for 365 days
and i'm happy for the draft you are
watching this possibly on the brf
gridiron twitter vr youtube thank you
for watching
just a reminder the only comments that
we are going to be watching
or reading throughout the show will be
on the br
app which i have on my phone right now
look there's our faces
uh the theme today quarterbacks
okay the biggest one always it's likely
we're gonna have two at the top of the
draft but what about the rest
i know the comment section is excited
for trask
chilling just kidding uh and as always
submit your videos in the nfl draft
community we will pick
three different videos to show during
our next show
we have three videos for this show and
they will be getting br
gridiron hoodies connor before we get
into your top 10 list
this quarterback class compared to let's
say
last year's with uh justin herbert
tuatanga viloa
the one and joe burrow the one before
with kyla murray the one before
that 2018 with the five quarterbacks how
does this year's class compare to the
classes of recent years i think it's
close to 2018 here lefco where
it's deep that's the difference right
last year of course we had a guy like
joe burrow that we knew was going number
one and this year
sure we have somebody like that trevor
lawrence but it's beyond that even as
good as justin herbert was
people had a lot of questions about him
last year same with tua coming off that
injury
this year you look at those first four
guys trevor lawrence zach wilson justin
fields trey lance
they are top five overall prospects for
me this year that is a tier one group of
players that i believe
can be franchise quarterbacks players
that i believe can win you a lot of
games and then you get outside of that
it gets interesting mac jones i think
he's an early second round guy but i
think he goes in the top 15 picks of
this draft and then you get into kyle
trask
and a lot of other developmental players
that we're going to break down today
connor actually can we put that graphic
up one more time because i think it's
important to
to separate these guys into tears so
conor you have the first
four as your blue chip tier and then you
have
mac jones almost as a tier on to himself
right the second
round but how do you break down your
tiers for this top ten well i think i
asked an important question at the top
left go and that is
is this a guy that can win you games on
his own or is he a guy you can win
with and i think that's the difference
between those first four
and mac jones and then when you get
outside of that we're going to talk
about it it gets a little different some
guys are
developmental players some guys are can
play in the structure
and once again you can win with them but
they might need a little more time
and then as you get towards the back end
of that you're looking at most likely
long-term backup quarterbacks
gotcha all right i do have an app
comment let's get to it first it is
about mac jones you were just mentioning
it
uh what is your opinion of mac jones in
the nfl also
what team is a good match for him asks
phillip monroe connor
yeah it's a great question now like i
said i think i differ a little bit than
the nfl when i watch mac jones i think
he's a very accurate pocket passer i
think he has a lot of arm talent in
terms of that pinpoint accuracy
i think you could see the touch accuracy
even on the deep ball which is really
important
but i just ask myself here lefko can he
win out of structure when the play
breaks down
is he a dynamic athlete that can make
something out of nothing
and i don't see that in my eyes he
compares you know kind of like an andy
dalton level player now i know people
will laugh at that because what andy
dalton's been
recently but there was a time where in a
really good bengals offense
he was obviously a very productive
player so i look at mac jones
and i think the best fits for him are
also the teams that will target him i
think maybe the patriots can move up and
go get him
we know the washington football team has
signed ryan fitzpatrick but they're
still looking for their long-term answer
and it's funny to bring this one up
because they signed andy dalton but i
think the bears have to look into
getting a little bit more aggressive for
the future of their quarterback
uh thoughts on his pro day and
where do you think he ends up if you had
to guess well i thought he ran a little
better than i expected he's somewhere
around a four
seven because we're not going to get
true official times there's a 468 a 472
submitted to the nfl
i don't see that necessarily on field
speed so i think when you look at it
the pro day was fine the arm is not in
the same category as those top four guys
just as simple as that and everybody
will ask themselves
you know what how much you did playing
with a bunch of round one wide receivers
probably around one running back and an
nfl offensive line because all those
guys are nfl level players a lot of
early draft picks
how much did that help him and it
clearly helped him a lot because these
are guys who see jaylen waddle
climb the rim on an underthrown ball
they can make plays like that for him
over and over again when things aren't
perfect
and guess what they just won't be that
perfect at the next level
he definitely fits that size profile if
the patriots were interested in them
uh one of the things that connor rogers
does so well
is give us prop bets for the draft and i
hear that you have one for mac jones
what is it
yeah it's my favorite one i've seen so
far and that is over under pick 15 and a
half now the odds have started to go
really against where this isn't as fun
but i'm going under
all the way when it released it was at
plus 100 from what i saw
lefko like i said just because i have
him as an or top of round
two maybe late round one kind of
quarterback prospect
does not mean that's where he's going
there's reaches on quarterbacks every
year
mack jones is a lock for the top 15. go
get your free money
uh and just for everyone that is curious
about the draft order
the patriots have pick 15 and it seems
like that's why the line was put right
there at 15
and a half it is time to go to our first
video
submission content this comes to us from
logoholtz32
let's take a listen hey connor and lefko
logan halst here from grimes iowa stick
to football hall of fame member
quick question for you out of all the
teams in the nfl
are there any that you see as a surprise
team to try and jump up into the top 10
to take a quarterback that people
haven't talked about a lot yet
thanks halloween
hall of famer a loyal one logan he
always brings great draft questions to
the table and i think when you look at
it
i guess you know there's no surprise
anymore because we play out every
scenario in our heads at this point like
i just said
i think mac jones go in the top 15 if
you listen the teams that i mentioned
a lot of them are outside the top 15. so
team those teams are looking to move up
probably washington
the bears if you want to get really deep
in the weeds here
i think the steelers are just going to
run things back one more year i don't
think they'll be overly aggressive to
get into the top 15 of this draft
maybe the saints because every time we
look at the saints and go hey they can't
do something whether it's the salary cap
or the draft they don't care they floor
it and find a way so i guess the saints
would be the team
that i look at and say hey sure they got
jameis they got taysom hill
neither of them are long-term answers in
terms of how they're being paid and how
they're viewed right now by the
organization
maybe it is the new orleans saints uh
let's do a quick
recap of your top five guys you have
trevor lawrence at one
zack wilson at two justin fields out of
ohio state three
trey lance the dual threat quarterback
the real solid athlete at
north dakota state and mack joe's five
out of alabama
i kind of want to run through these a
bunch we've talked about trevor lawrence
to the jaguars now on
on two different episodes but i am
curious your comps for trevor lawrence
yeah i look at trevor lawrence and i
think he is what josh allen has become
i don't think he's what josh allen was
coming out of wyoming but what josh
allen has developed into with the bills
you see the size
you see the mobility and you see how
tough he is and the throwback comp for
me would be john elway so a mix of those
kind of players but the more
relevant the more recent one is josh
allen you see that red zone running
you see the ability to get the ball into
really really tight spaces and
honestly he's just a smart tough player
that
has no problem creating on the run in
the second level the field lowering the
shoulder
breaking tackles the arm strength is
essentially
limitless i think the deep accuracy
isn't perfect right now lefko it's
something that we don't talk about
enough with trevor lawrence and i think
that's something that
josh allen really needed to work on and
has gotten a lot better at over the
years so if you're looking to nitpick
something there
that would be it for me with trevor
lawrence but i mean he's someone that i
think within two years will easily be a
top 10 quarterback in the nfl
our good buddy chris sims set the nfl
draft world ablaze when he said zach
wilson was ahead of trevor lawrence i
have not seen anybody else say that
did it make you question your rankings
at all and where do you stand on zack
wilson
it didn't make me question anything
because he's my third ranked overall
player and second quarterback and just
the player that i absolutely love
and i think with those compact mechanics
and how effortlessly the ball gets out
it reminded me of russell wilson now
he's bigger than russell wilson but
you get some of that mobility everything
just looks so effortlessly when he
releases the ball and finds it's really
any point of the field outside the deep
hashes down the field
he sees the field really really well you
can see the cannon that he has so i
think when you look at it with zach
wilson
he's somebody that is he perfect for any
system not necessarily i like him
in a shanahan kind of offense which
he'll probably go to at number two to
the new york jets where you roll him out
cut the fields in half get him on the
move the throwing on the run is
absolutely special
and i think the only real question that
the nfl has with this guy
is nothing to do with talent but
durability because he's had a banged up
shoulder
and a banged up thumb before that i
think both required some kind of surgery
or procedure but he came back in 2020
and looked like the best
version of himself so he's probably
going to be the second overall pick in
this draft let go
and i think he is maybe the most one of
the most exciting players to watch in
this draft when you turn on the film
uh it is connor rogers because that s at
the end is actually a money sign
uh are you willing to bet on the fact
that zach wilson will be the second pick
of the draft
yeah i am i don't love the odds i
believe they're hovering around minus
200 so you're not really gonna make
much on this at all but i feel good
enough about it that you know and
everybody has their different opinions
we've seen
oh maybe the jets will run it back with
sam darnold maybe justin fields or trey
lance will sneak up into that
i can't find anybody close to the new
york jets organization
that thinks this isn't what they'll do
everybody thinks that they're going to
trade sam darnold whether it's draft
weekend or before that
and take zach wilson second overall so i
feel pretty good about him being the
number two overall pick
let me actually get to an app comment
about sam darnold and zack wilson this
is from sammy
sam is dope uh in your opinion as a
prospect is zach wilson better than sam
darnold yes he is i had sam darnold
you know behind lamar jackson in that
class behind baker mayfield in that
class
somewhere in the 20s in that first round
range where
zach wilson i just told you will be my
third overall player so
i think when you look at it i just think
the mechanics are much better i think he
sees the field better
darnold was somebody that had a lot of
problems i think with timing
and deep accuracy at you know when you
turned on the film at usc and it never
really got better with the jets no
matter how bad the situation was
i think wilson's best trade is this ball
placement throwing the ball vertically
so different players as much as
everybody wonders
hey is this any different of a situation
for me it is zach wilson's the better
prospect
uh just some nfl breaking news it looks
like malcolm butler is going to be
another
player signing with the arizona
cardinals big pickup for them
uh it was a need we'll just see is it
the malcolm butler that showed great
promise in year one with tennessee or is
the one last year that was sort of
picked on a bit let's go to a
quarterback that i'm seeing get
mentioned
a lot in the comments section uh and
we're gonna use nrg24s comment to get
there
do you think the panthers trade up to
three
for justin fields interesting set of
circumstances there
oh well i love that they called that out
because that's one of the teams i'd
written down for justin fields you know
the falcons probably a long shot after
the way they restructured matt ryan's
contract but then you look at the
broncos and panthers
and i think the panthers know they need
to be aggressive to upgrade their
quarterback situation
and why not go get this guy you talk
about accuracy
once again all three levels on the move
a big body that can take those hits
in the open field a leader he really
has it all and i think the only question
that people have is
you know how long he held the ball at
times at the college level and will that
get better at the nfl but in the right
system i think that will improve over
time
like it does with a lot of young
quarterbacks so justin fields power arm
can push the ball vertically when things
break down he's not a hey i'll pick up
and take what's there
he said hey how am i going to run around
this linebacker
or through this safety and turn eight
yards into 25 yards and that excites me
about him at the nfl
uh who does he remind you of and if it
wasn't going to be carolina
which is what was brought up there in
the question what other teams do you
think would be able to use his skill
sets best
he reminds me of dak prescott somebody
that once again is that big body that
can get out of the pocket
and very very accurate looks very
comfortable and you just see how
effortlessly
he can fit the ball you know outside of
the hashes or in the middle of the field
with timing and touch it's a howitzer
when you look at this arm so once again
the big body toughness and i think that
mindset and that accuracy
is why he reminds me of dak prescott and
i say the panthers
when you look at joe brady there i think
he can execute a lot of the timing
they're going to ask of him
and you get a little creative with him
as a runner i also like the broncos
a lot because of the receiving weapons
they have for him it's something i've
said on this show before
you know cortland sutton can win down
the field you know kj hamler has the
speed to win down the field
jerry judy is going to be your
intermediate weapon all the playmakers
are there for justin fields because
everybody goes oh well
he struggled without chris alabe of
course he struggled without his one of
his top two wide receivers but you go
into the broncos
you have the weapons for him to excel
and that's something that's really
exciting sure dude jerry judy man showed
a lot of promise all right so justin
fields
by that notion uh quarterbacks going one
two three in the draft would be quite a
sight to behold
uh the next quarterback that you have
the final four
uh in your blue chip tier is trey lance
we have a comment here from brendan
francis
does trey lance get enough credit for
being in a pro style system
which is interesting i heard that a lot
when carson wentz was coming out of
north dakota state
uh what do you think about this quandary
connor
i don't i don't think he does and i like
this question from brandon francis
because i think with trey lance all we
ever hear about is
he had one great year of fcs ball and
then he didn't get to play this year
besides the showcase game and i guess
i'm guilty of it at times as well but
some of the first
notes in my scouting report of trey
lance is he is tasked with making
checks at the line of scrimmage to get
in and out of plays and i think
when you watch the film sure some of it
is one read
and then go which really just means if
the first read is an open run and you
see it right there
actually but when you're this good of a
runner and you can run through people
that's okay i like having to do that
with a 19 year old quarterback make
things
a little easier on him but there are
examples of him let go going to the line
of scrimmage
reading pressure reading the field
before the snap
and then he knows where to go with the
football so i love that question because
listen i love that but nfl teams really
really value that with trey lance i
don't think this whole perception of
he can't be on the nfl field as a rookie
in my opinion is nonsense maybe he
doesn't come out of the gate as a
starter
but i think he'll surprise a lot of
people with how smart he is and how
ready to go he is
and you look at the teams i would love
i've said it before
i would love to see a new england or
49ers
go get this guy because they have the
infrastructures for him to succeed
whether it's
jimmy g is your starter out of the gate
whether it's cam newton is your starter
out of the game we saw a lot of those
power run concepts new england ran last
year
you can do that with trey lance so i
think the spotlight wouldn't be
on him as much in those scenarios to
come in and be the savior
which has crumbled a lot of top three
pick quarterbacks over the years
and i think he could develop over time
with good coaches
with good offensive lines and schemes
that really tailor to his needs
what's interesting is i'm i have your
comp here
for for trey lance and it's steve mcnair
and what's interesting to me is your
comp for justin fields was dak prescott
steve mcnair to me i mean dak prescott
hopes to be like steve mcnair that's
that's
pretty lofty praise for you for trey
yeah it is i love this player i've said
it since really the summer that i think
there was a lot of special traits here
on film from 2019 where
you know people kind of mocked this i
said it somewhere where i thought
if he had a season this year and he was
phenomenal
people would have made the number one
pick discussion a little bit more
difficult and this was out of his
control he didn't sit there and go not
playing there was no season to be
had for him in the fall besides that one
showcase game so
once again great arm strength he does
sail the ball a little high because of
you know a little hiccup in mechanics
that will be cleaned up
but once again really smart good runner
great leader strong arm he checks every
box
playing in that pro style offense once
again he sees the field
all of that is there with trey lance
where i'm a big believer
i'm a big buyer as a top five pick in
this draft and quite frankly
people are sitting there and thinking
he's this bargain prospect you can get
at eight nine ten eleven twelve
i'm not seeing it i don't see how this
guy makes it outside of those top six
picks
that's my other question jacksonville at
one jets at two
the dolphins are loaded and can move
that pick probably if the price is right
and they just drafted tua
and then the atlanta falcons is there a
chance that we go
qb for the first four picks in this
draft connor
very easily i think we could see
auctions with number three and the
number four picks why not go up and get
your guy and i think
i've already heard rumblings that the
panthers are one of those teams that
you know they're preparing for every
scenario they're preparing to be
aggressive to get their face of the
franchise over there
the bears you have a gm that's you know
trying to save his career right now
washington football team they've done so
many good things where i think there's
less
panic over there especially after
bringing in ryan fitzpatrick but i think
they'll have their eyes on moving up new
england
the 49ers all of those teams so if those
teams at three and four
the dolphins and the falcons say hey
picks for sale
come and get it teams will come up and
pay a hefty price to do so
i am getting an alert from my producer
that the nfl
draft producer sean mcmanus is actually
commenting in the stream right now let's
see what his comment was
what should be on this year's draft show
drinking game
oh man a favorite in the past
i mean that's a phenomenal one i think
we're gonna have to lean on the audience
to see what they want to do and it's
probably just
dumb things i say like once again or i'm
excited about this guy
or every time i have to fix my hair or
something stupid like that but if you
want to look at the draft
i think we up the ante i think you know
i don't know how much drinking i can
encourage
on this show but i think if a running
back goes in round one
it's going to be cause for celebration i
think we set over unders
on offensive line really strong class i
think we set over unders on quarterbacks
and wide receivers and things along the
line of that
i would also add does lefko
explode in anger with the sixth pick
from the eagles
should definitely be on there that's
like finish your drink um
and and really this is just gonna be a
tease
i found out who is joining
connor and i on oh yeah and i'm not
here to ruin the surprise but the amount
of excitement that i have bottled up
boy is it going to be great and the
amount of drinking game stuff that we
can do around this guy
it has exceeded my expectation conor i'm
very excited i know you are as well
i can't wait i mean i've been banging
the table uh
for this person to join us and the fact
that it sounds like it's coming true
it's going to be an incredible br draft
show to be working with this person
during this special and let's go before
we move on i got to ask you because it's
something that is not being discussed
enough it almost seems like
it's assumed at this point because the
signing of joe flacco
because jalen hurts is there but when
you hear me
and i'm just one man in this big draft
world gush about these quarterbacks
and your team is sitting there with you
know a bit of an
unsure at their future quarterback with
the sixth overall pick
does it make you kind of wonder hey
should we maybe be considering taking
one of these guys
no i i
look i am biased i love jalen hurts
i think that people are forgetting that
brandon brooks missed all of last
season's won the best offensive lineman
in the nfl
i think what i'm hearing as an eagles
fan as you're talking is
we need to put this six pick up for sale
if some of these quarterbacks get down
there
because the secondary needs work the
d-line is getting old
uh we could use some more weapons at
wide receiver and tight end especially
if they move zach hurts there's a lot of
holes so
i'm watching micah parsons run a 4-3-5
and the eagles just don't value
linebackers but boy i'd like the next
patrick willis for the next 10 years
uh kyle pitts jamar chase but the main
thing i hear from you is
they there's a lot of value at this pick
if any of those quarterbacks fall but
i'm
i'm a jalen hurts believer that's just
who i am
yeah and i think that's justified and
i'm with you that the value of the pick
is tremendous because we know
quarterbacks are going one and two
we'll see what the teams at three four
and five end up doing
but somebody's gonna get stubborn and
not move and take their guy and there's
a chance
at the sixth overall pick maybe it's
just trey lance or mac jones left on the
board and somebody panics and says
take everything so we can come up and
grab this guy before the quarterbacks
are gone
yeah because the the benefit of the spot
and i'll wrap up quickly is we don't
know if detroit is planning on having
uh jared goffel uh for a long time
they're picked seven but more
importantly
carolina and denver are picks eight and
nine and you'd think teams would want to
jump ahead of them we already talked
about
mack jones so those are connor's top
five quarterbacks now let's get down
to your tier three and we have had
people in our comment section
constantly commenting about kyle trask
so why don't we use one of them
la mickey mouse simply comments trask
uh i know nothing about this guy connor
so please
illuminate me what do i need to know
about kyle tress
big body touch thrower that has overcome
a lot
really a no-star kind of recruit not a
ton of expectations coming into florida
i think those were on felipe franks
and all tress did was overachieve over
time
6'5 240 pounds i don't think the arm is
great but i think the accuracy
is very very good i think he's a tough
player we've seen him play through
injuries at times
but he's a limited athlete with a
somewhat limited arm
and i think the decision making is not
perfect and the problem is
when you try to force throws and you
have an
average or mediocre kind of arm it can
get you in trouble so i think with trask
be somebody that you're looking at
probably in round three i think over
time a team will develop him with the
hopes that he can be a starter but it
goes back to my conversation lefko
he's somebody that you can win games
with after some refinement
not somebody that'll always just put the
team on his back and win you games and
you see it throwing a kyle pitts or
kedarius tony
players like that that can really take
over he did a great job finding those
guys
with timing the soft spot of the zone
really excelled in dan mullen's offense
but
the physical profile is just not there
as a first rounder
what you just said scares me you were
talking about mac jones and having all
the talent
around him the fact that kyle pitts and
i just from hearing
the comment section talk about candarius
tony like those are special special
players
who does he remind you of and where
would you like to see trask though that
you think would work well for him
he reminds me of matt job just that huge
body at six foot five 240 maybe even
bigger where
sure he's not a great overall athlete
but in the structure of the offense he's
very accurate and understands where to
go with the football
and that's what schwab was in his best
years so i think what trask
you're looking at a team that once again
doesn't need him to come in and be the
savior
or come in and constantly you know break
when things break down pick up 20-yard
gains or he has pretty good feel in the
pocket as you can see there which is
definitely an important trade as he
finds cadarius tony but
i look at the steelers that i think will
be looking for a mid-round quarterback
when
we've seen big ben just have an
unbelievable amount of injuries over the
years
and we know the kind of playmakers they
have they get juju back on a one-year
deal you have chase claypool
they always have a talented offensive
line a well-coached offensive line
trash can come in and manage the game if
something happened to big ben
and i think that's where you capitalize
on value because
you know those other five guys they're
going in the first round but trask you
might be able to get them outside the
top 60.
so i'm looking at your you had the top
four
mac jones of his own tier and then in
this third tier along with kyle trask
davis mills out of stanford i feel like
i've been hearing about this guy for a
long time
who is the comp what do you think of the
prospect he's jimmy g
light is what i would say you know not
the full version of jimmy g
but i guess the poor man's version the
jimmy g light so when you look at him
coming out of a pro style offense at
stanford which i just gushed about that
with trey lance at north dakota state so
you see him working under center you see
him working in shotgun right here
the touch accuracy is what jumps out to
me he knew before the snap where he's
going with the ball because simi pahoko
is a bigger more talented speed speedy
guy against that corner and he drops it
in the bucket right here
the feel how is that rush coming and i
got to get the ball out it gets out on
time so
only 11 games is a starter you need some
more experience but the shoulder dip to
buy himself time
and then drop it in the bucket not a
great athlete
but good enough on the move so that's
why it reminds me of jimmy g that
is the arm perfect no but more
importantly he's accurate and he finds a
way to get it to his big targets
outside the hatches and give them a
chance to go up and make a play on the
football so
davis mills is this rhythm thrower that
is a little raw because he doesn't have
a ton of starting experience
but the arm talent checks the box once
again like mac jones like kyle trask
not gonna give you much when the play
breaks down but does he know where to go
with the football
yes does he have enough accuracy to do
it consistently
i think so where makes sense for him
then
after saying all that i think tennessee
i think when you look at it sure they
have ryan tannehill there but they have
not
found a backup of the future i think
deshaun kaiser's on that roster
but go you're gonna get davis mills in
round three or four and you're gonna
develop him
a similar kind of way to kyle trash but
i think he's a better fit in the
tennessee offense that can use a lot of
play action boots i know arthur smith
left
so we'll see how much carryover there is
but you look at tennessee green bay
it'll be the jets and the 49ers they run
similar passing concepts to an extent
and that's where davis mills fits in and
you know obviously he's lagging out that
one to the pylon there
once again not this dynamic athlete but
gives you enough
at all three levels as a passer and
we've seen what they did with ryan
tannehill
i think that's a good soft landing for
davis mills
yeah desean kaiser and logan woodside
the backups there in tennessee i was
thinking as you were talking about the
touch passes and
being good at finding outside receivers
that works well with aj brown
if this kid has to come in there in a
pinch or if something happens
with ryan tannehill okay now we are
getting down to your tier four
and it's interesting because i'm
bringing up our guy again chris sims
he had this guy as his fourth overall
quarterback
will kell and mon be a first round pick
next the next
j king i can imagine this caught your
attention when
sims rated on that high but what what in
your actuality is the real kellen monde
who is the real kellen mont oh man it's
tough to figure out because early on in
his career it was not pretty the
decision making was bad the accuracy was
inconsistent
but he really cut down those turnovers
in 2020 and
he's a good athlete right you look at
him standing in the pocket is why he's
getting all these colin kaepernick
comparisons because of that
build but a nice catch and run ball from
telling mom that was something that
stood out to me in 2020
he's starting to get timing down a
little bit better right here
can you fit it in between the corner and
the safety that's not something i saw
him do a lot early on in his career
but when he does it's very impressive go
through reads there's pro-style concepts
on that play he looked at the slot
looked right and then went back left to
the open man
so he's a player that is he ready to
start i don't think so because once
again i think the timing's a little off
there's almost too much velocity on his
short and underneath stuff where he gets
out of control
the decision making did improve this
year but it's not
perfect but he does give you a decent
amount as a runner i think you can get
creative with him in the red zone and
let's not forget
you know when kaepernick came in the
league that's something the niners did
where there was red zone packages for
him
i think teams will look to do that with
kellen mond where can you get him
involved in option plays
inside the 20. so kelmont to me i don't
think he goes in the first round if he
did that would be the shock
of the draft for me but it wouldn't
shock me if he snuck into day two after
being projected as this day three guy
for a while because of that raw
athleticism and arm strength
you said before with wilson you wanted
that shanahan system because they could
use that athleticism
uh what is a good fit for mond where
it's not
look we've seen this a lot the big kid
out of buffalo just
you know some you got to find the right
system for this to actually work what's
what's a good system for mom yeah it
would be tough for me to constantly get
him on the move i think the deep balls
you know they hang at times i think
they're a little bit under
thrown so he's not perfect as a thrower
on the run
yet i think when you look at him you
know you might like to see hey can he
back up in baltimore can he be somebody
that can give our running concepts
and push the ball down the field
vertically keep things kind of simple
where you're saying
hey we know you have the arm strength
yes i have a problem with the deep
accuracy
but i think that can improve over times
if he fixes his base of his mechanics
see the velocity in the middle of the
field
that's something that stands out but
right here sure you're not going to run
the exact option in the nfl
but read option plays will work with him
at the next level because he has that
long leggy
build up speed as a runner and that will
threaten the outside of a defense
while opening up things a little bit
more for your wide receivers
all right yeah backup quarterback is
always interesting early on i'm going to
do a shout out to steele ko because he
just asked and i just saw it so shout
out to you
uh next one we have up in the kellenmann
fourth region
out of wake forest jamie newman we've
reached the part of the show
where i've i don't even know if this is
real but will
drogalis asks who is the best
quarterback no one is talking about will
guess what i'm definitely not talking
about jamie newman
connor who the heck is jamie newman fill
me in
well jamie newman is somebody with a lot
of raw talent that didn't play
this year he decided to opt out after
transferring to georgia
showed some talent throwing to sage
sharat while at wake forest
another one of those big-bodied passers
not fast but a strong runner especially
once again
inside the 10 yard line inside that five
yard line where you can get him on
sneaks and draw plays
the arm talent is really really good let
go but i think he's just a touch
late on a lot of throws you see him
throw down the field
he's got the velocity and the arm
strength to really push the ball
vertically but how would he be under
pressure at the next level i think is
the question so
i think you know when you miss a year of
football and you're already a raw
prospect that's going to hurt you and
that's why nobody's talking about jamie
newman but when you just
watch him in terms of raw talent and
what you can mold him to be
you know kind of goes back to what i
talked about with kellen monde a little
bit
maybe a team like seattle sits there and
i know there's a lot going on with russ
but in a perfect world where russ is the
future
of that offense he's somebody that you
can get on the move we know they love
throwing the ball down the field to a
guy like dk metcalf
and really once again at least threaten
you a little bit with his legs
and a big-bodied passer that can take
those hits that russell wilson did not
like so
jamie newman i don't think he's going to
go in the first three rounds of this
draft
but just based on that limited sample
size we saw at wake forest alone
he will hear his name called and be a
draft and stash kind of quarterback
we are getting ready to do rapid fire q
and a before we do
uh and before we get to this video
comment uh i have one quick question out
of nowhere for you connor i'm just
looking at the the draft and the rundown
the order washington at 19.
everyone's so excited about ryan
fitzpatrick we saw what happened the end
of last year
but do you think that they could be a
team with this window
with this elite defensive line a weak
division
that they can maximize that window by
maybe getting a rookie quarterback here
and
allowing some more money to flow what do
you think
i would like to see it i think the
problem is the demand in the market is
really really high and when you're
picking
at 19 in a weird year of winning the
division with a not so great record
you might be on the outside looking in
how aggressive
are you willing to go and maybe them
spending a lot of money and free agency
left go
is a sign of that i said that with new
england as well where i look at the
spending and go
maybe they are a team that's operating
like we're not going to be making all of
those draft picks what if we package
19 next year's first and a couple of day
two picks how high can we get can we
jump carolina
can we jump denver because the player i
would like to see operate in that
offense
is justin fields throwing the ball deep
to curtis samuel
giving terry mclaren a lot of chances on
those jump balls
and we know that they're a team that
will be very very eager to run the
football so
that's who excites me but i just think
they will be out bid
i think the value and it hurts
washington it hurts the bears at 19 and
20.
a lot of those teams that are picking in
the top 10 like your eagles that want to
get out
they don't want to go that far back i
always wonder would washington
have doubts on fields just because they
drafted dwayne haskins just because of
the teams and all that because
you know sometimes it gets that simple
okay let's get uh to a video comment
andrew magnuson i've heard this name
before man good to have you on the show
let's hear what he has to say
we don't have it well guess what conor
i'm gonna read you what he said
uh sorry andrew no no uh prime time uh
for you
he said a lot of mock drafts have
falcons going quarterback at four
i just don't get it uh we we've talked
about that a bunch
uh do you see a lot of sense in it or
are you someone like andrew that you
just don't see it you'd rather them do
something else
i don't see it i think after
restructuring matt ryan's deal where the
money is more spread out into future
years it's something that would really
really surprise me i think that was a
sign of hey
we think we could still win with matt
ryan right now and i'm sure that was a
conversation when they brought in arthur
smith where
he comes in there and they say hey are
you looking for your quarterback in the
future
or do you feel good running things with
matt for a couple years so
you know arthur smith is somebody that
has kyle shanahan connection so all it
was one quick phone call
kyle shanahan loved working with matt
ryan so no surprise there
i think that they are going to look to
either trade that pick or continue to
supplement that roster with premium
talent so
i could absolutely be talked into
getting justin fields in atlanta
i would absolutely love it but i just
don't think it's happening
uh yeah just because of what arthur
smith did with the athleticism of
tannehill and the play actions it's very
enticing with someone that can move
uh we have found the video from andrew
magnuson he is getting a hoodie
he deserves some face time so let's show
andrew magnuson's beautiful grill
hey guys i keep seeing the falcons take
a quarterback at four in a lot of mock
drafts and i just don't get it
matt ryan's still under contract and
they're gonna be paying them for big
bucks for the next couple years
so you won't be able to take advantage
of that rookie quarterback deal
and matt ryan's still pretty good help
me make sense of this i don't get it
guys
all right we're not talking about it
anymore magnuson but we did show your
face congratulations on
kyle pitts cow pits would be fun
especially because
we saw what arthur did with johnny smith
arthur's just so creative with different
positions passing you may not even need
a quarterback i mean he's got defensive
lineman throwing the football
uh let us get to a one comment that is
not about the quarterbacks at all
how far does caleb farley fall after his
back surgery from david h connor
filled me in i know that he was one of
your top guys uh
what happened what was the surgery
what's the timeline i need info
yeah this is the not so fun side of the
lead-up to the giraffe unfortunately for
caleb
uh farley it's it's gonna be you know
essentially a herniated disc kind of
operation and normally you look at that
and go hey that can be a one-and-done
you see the talent we know he has talent
he was my cornerback
too when we did the blue chip show only
behind patrick certain
but for a lot of people in the draft
community and nfl teams he was the top
corner i believe he had
22 passes defended in just 24 games so
the ball production is tremendous
he's an elite athlete with elite size i
compared him to marshawn lattimore
but because of this injury history now
let's go he had some back problems in
2019
he's been training all year he didn't
play in 2020 and now you need a back
procedure
the problem is i still believe caleb
farley's a very talented player
but i've seen this song and dance way
too many times in my short time covering
the nfl draft full time talking to teams
they're very very afraid of taking
injury risk in round one they're very
open to it in round two so i think for
caleb farley especially after the day
jc horn had at his pro day i think
certain is going to go off the board
before farley i think jc horn's going to
go off the board before farley
there is some talk that maybe even greg
newsom from northwestern goes off the
board before caleb farley so
extreme talent i'm rooting for him to
get things right and be back on the
football field
but it could be kind of like what we saw
with miles jack or jalen smith where
we know their round one talents top 15
players those are no brainer decisions
but because of medical might be sitting
there night two with
our very very special guest and saying
hey this guy will come off the board in
the next couple picks
i would also say that in a year
where they can't do individual medical
testing because there was no combine
and they can't have their doctors do all
the poking and prodding to make them
confident we see this every year we saw
this
with reggie ragland as the one that i'll
never forget where
that questionable medical report comes
out on the day of the draft which leads
to a very precipitous fall
also when you factor in it's a back you
know this isn't an acl
this isn't a leg this isn't a shoulder
this is a back
just it's a very scary thing and i i
remember you talking this was the most
talented corner in the draft definitely
something to keep our eye on by the way
these are rapid fire questions
and we are not being rapid so let's get
to the next one uh number three rapid
fire question what round do you think
sam ellinger gets drafted
from trudes10 connor i'll say round six
uh limited size
limited overall arm ability but you know
once again maybe somebody that can find
his way as a long-term backup so round
six or seven for sam ellenger
hmm yeah i like sam okay
z seifert seven who takes the first
running back not
which one is it but where do you think
he goes
oh man i think it would be miami at 18
or even with a move back i think i like
that miami at 18. if we get a round one
running back i think it will be
miami and i think that it'll probably be
naji harris
if they took one i still like arizona
i think arizona would be a lot of fun i
know who's not indy
okay d dylan 408 last question would the
raiders draft
any of these quarterbacks they just
brought back marcus mariota on a very
low deal
derek carr i feel like is the ultimate
mendoza line either you hate him you
love him he's just
right in the middle do you think that
raiders go after any of these
quarterbacks john
gruden qb camp i do gruden is the
quarterback collector
i think when you look at the breakdown
of kellen monde i think that's the
perfect guy right there it's somebody
that he might watch and go hey
this guy reminds me of colin kaepernick
and he gets all excited about the
running and the throwing and the
highlight kind of plays and says
hey how do i get more of these highlight
reel kind of plays out of him than the
low light plays of the inaccuracies
gordon is this believer in
i can fix every single mechanical floor
decision making flaw and if you
honestly have that kind of ego in a good
way no
no insult there then kellen mond is the
perfect prospect for you in round three
or four
guys thank you as always for joining us
in the comment section whether you're
watching on twitter whether you're
watching on youtube or in the brf where
we got to a lot of the questions
uh let me put in uh i'm gonna put in an
app
uh comment i'm gonna do a little very
romantic heart
thank you to all the listeners in there
um and if you are listening on the left
go show i want to shout out the
regulators for the music you guys are
great we are doing this
every thursday 1pm eastern really
the best place to watch this in the brf
because then i can see your comments
next week workout warriors which i'm
sure we'll be talking about micah
parsons just did running around in boxer
briefs
but the main question that i'm gonna
have for connor after each one is
is this real or are these just numbers
we see it every year guys go out there
and show out in the workouts
but are they for real when the lights
come on
and we're playing 15 minute quarters
submit your videos
in the nfl draft community if we play
your video looking at you magnuson
who will be sending you a br gridiron
hoodie magnus and i would recommend
you got to stick to football hoodie uh
pull over now you're going to get a
gridiron hoodie your whole closet is
bleacher report man and we appreciate it
uh thank you guys connor before we go
uh anything about quarterbacks any draft
news that you want to get out we got a
few minutes
well i think you know there's a couple
interesting pro day notes here and i
mentioned it in some of the lead up in
that draft community in the app which
has been a lot of fun really love seeing
everybody post in there
rondell moore one of the most
interesting players in this draft he
comes in at five foot seven
how many receivers left go have a lot of
success at five foot seven
i'm betting on him i think he will be
one but it created some conversation of
this player
running back elite testing times across
the board
i wrote slot only in my notes
manufactured touches
screens drag routes jet sweeps all those
things for rondale more
i think he has become one of the most
intriguing players that will hear his
name called
in round two of this draft i'm really
excited about him
i don't care how short he is he's built
like an absolute rock
it always makes me laugh the the chatter
that pro days create on draft twitter
each year
yeah it's a little crazy to realize he's
5'7 tyreek hill is 510
and you're like man that is a tiny guy
and let's give a little love
uh to some guys that have good nfl genes
left go how about
joe horn's son jc horn at his pro day
just
absolutely killing it and for those that
missed it
i will read you some numbers here i mean
you're talking about a corner that's six
foot one 205 pounds
33 inch arms 4-3-9-40 41.5
vertical so joe horn his kid is going to
be
i think a star corner in the nfl and
patrick certain
the second six foot two 208 pounds
32 and a half inch arms four four two
forty thirty nine inch vertical
he's a clone of xavier rhodes to me who
actually just signed a one-year deal to
go back to the co
connor you said you were worried about
his athleticism and then he runs a
four-figure so wrong it's more twitch
left go
i will say that not deep speed length
explosiveness
it's more twitch side to side lateral
agility
but you use him as a boundary corner a
pressed
man corner on the outside he'll be a
very very good one
man eagles too high at six we'll see
connor rogers you are the man
thank you as always uh br draft
community we cannot wait to tell you who
will be joining us on the desk have a
great day we will see you next week
thursday one o'clock eastern have a good
[Music]
you